Alors, y a un nouveau prêtre en ville ?
Paraît qu'il est formidable.
Il est comment ?
Il est jeune.
Moi c'est surtout sa voix que j'ai apprécié.
C'est parce que vous manquez d'âme qu'il arrive à toutes vous allumer comme ça, c'est tout.
C'est bon, parle pour toi, hein.
C'est bien d'être venue.
(Rire étouffé)
C'est en ennemie que je suis ici.
Vous croyez ?
Il y a longtemps que vous ne vous êtes pas confessée, n'est-ce pas ?
Je ne crois pas en Dieu.
Est-ce que vous mentez, quelque fois ?
La dernière fois c'était à un soldat allemand.
Un de ceux qui passent dans votre église.
Ça compte ou pas, Monsieur l'Abbé ?
- Je saurai trouver les mots.
- Pour me convertir ?
C'est peut-être vous qui finirez par me faire changer d'avis.
Ça vous convient mieux, tête de mule ?
Qu'est-ce que vous foutez là ?
Et toi, qu'est-ce que tu penses du Père Morin ?
Il est sympathique… Mais son assurance m'exaspère.
Me donne envie de tout faire pour le déstabiliser.
Quand je vous écoute, j'ai l'impression que vous me parlez depuis une autre planète.
Qu'est-ce que ça peut vous faire au fond, qu'il y ait un Dieu ou qu'il n'y en ait pas ?
Comment, "qu'est ce que ça peut me faire" ? Mais ça change tout !
Vous avez tout compris.
On dira que c'est le Diable qui vous a fait un croche-patte.
Il va falloir qu'on passe beaucoup de temps ensemble…
Je m'en réjouis d'avance.
Et qui vous dit que c'est pas réciproque ?
Je lui parle et j'ai l'impression qu'il s'en fout…
Que sa tête est ailleurs.
Les Allemands ont arrêté dix otages.
Ils vont les fusiller sur la place.
Le père Morin ?